[Music]
it was up guys mkbhd here and this is
the new 16 inch macbook pro this this
right here and I'm here to tell you this
is in fact the best laptop that Apple
has ever made it's not the one I would
personally get but it's gonna be great
for a lot of people so the 15 inch
macbook pro that this replaces was their
previous highest and best laptop and it
was pretty good in some ways but it had
problems real problems it had thermal
overheating problems that I've talked
about in my video and it had keyboard
problems so this new version of their
highest end Pro laptop is better in
every way and fixes specifically those
problems it's kind of like Apple hire to
listen to the people team that's just
going through their lineup one by one
during the year and fixing them based on
what people have said about them the
iPad pro how people wanted functional
USB type-c give the people what they
want air pods Pro oh you wanted better
sound and a better fit in the ear and
noise cancellation give the people what
they want
iPhone 11 Pro oh ultra white is in you
wanted a bigger battery with the thicker
iPhone give the people what they want so
now here they are
they've derived on the MacBook Pro so
they fixed the keyboard and made it
better
they made the laptop slightly thicker
and gave it a bigger battery they fix
the thermal performance issues and they
gave it a bigger screen with thinner
bezels wherever this imaginary team is
at Apple good looks you did almost
everything right here so for the most
part the design is still the same but as
you may have heard the new 16 inch is
slightly bigger in every dimension than
the 15-inch MacBook Pro it still fits in
most of the same backpacks and sleeves
for me it still is fine in my peak
design everyday 20 liters which is a
smaller one so it's not exactly the same
footprint but it's very close only
difference I really noticed was the
slightly higher weight it's around 4.3
pounds now instead of 4 but for what you
get out of this slightly bigger chassis
I'll absolutely take it if we start at
the keyboard it's no mechanical keyboard
or anything but it's this new version
which has switched back to the scissor
switches and it's a significantly better
typing experience than those old
butterfly keys there's actually some
real millimeter key travel now they
should be more durable and they're just
generally better to type on which for me
comes from the fact that the keys are a
bit more stable so you're back to
getting more confident key presses even
when you're not necessarily pressing in
the center of the key so yeah for me
someone who never really cared that much
about the keyboard and with the new
butterfly switch I just kind of got used
to it I didn't really expect to care
this much about the keyboard but now
that I've been typing on it I do it is
much better oh and they also changes the
layout a bit as you may have noticed
dedicated Escape key is now separate
from the touch bar thankfully which that
touch bar still seems to freeze all the
time for me and the touch ID sensor the
power button is also now separated on
the right hand side not as big of a deal
still works great for unlocking and then
you also now have the inverted T layout
for the arrow keys which people seem
really pumped about but I honestly
didn't mind the bigger sideways arrow
keys at all they're actually easier for
me to hit but whatever I'm not a
complete touch typist and then the
slight extra thickness gives it a bit
more room for a larger battery in fact
the largest legally allowed battery for
domestic flights in the u.s. a hundred
watt hours and the battery life has been
excellent especially when you're not
pushing it I had a five hour flight
where I basically the whole time was
using airplane Wi-Fi for email light web
browsing and writing parts of this video
and landed at about 60% which is nuts of
course your mileage may vary you know if
you're editing in Final Cut Pro yes the
battery life is still going to be trash
or if you're doing anything heavy like
that but of course you might as well
just plug in if you're doing something
like that so I do appreciate a thicker
laptop for that all-day battery peace of
mind also the new brick the new brick it
comes with is a 96 watts and I know
probably shouldn't do this but this is
what tends to become like my Universal
charge everything fast charger for USB
type C so the laptop my iPad pro my
phone my Sony wireless headphones they
all charge via a USB type-c it's like
the universal fast charger that just
works with everything right so the specs
of this laptop here we have the Intel
Core I 9 we have 64 gigs of ram we have
these new graphics cards and 4 terabytes
of storage here there's also an option
to go up to 8 terabytes of storage now
which is honestly incredible and it's
not even that overpriced so while it is
expensive having it be only 2200 bucks
for 8 terabytes and essentially never
having to use an external drive again is
actually kind of reasonable for people
considering buying one of these I'd say
the order of upgrades should probably
always be GPU first the new graphics are
excellent and then I'd go upgrade the
RAM and you can go up to 64 but it
starts at already 16 gigs and then CPU
now you may be saying wait this is the
same overheating I 9 CPU as the last
model and you'd be right this is the
same CPU but now because this laptop is
a little bit thicker and in a bit of a
larger footprint the heatsink is a bit
bigger and the fan blades are a little
bit larger and they have some room to
rearrange components inside in a way
that landed at 28 percent better thermal
efficiency and basically that's allowed
the MacBook Pro to stay at higher clock
speeds from much longer durations
without throttling down and if I'm being
candid it also just seems like it's less
afraid to just spin up the fans quickly
whenever it needs them and just be loud
sometimes so the difference is you'll
notice improvements under sustained
loads so for things like rendering a
large project compiling code exporting a
video a lot of things like that that
people do on MacBook Pros so to bring
that into daily performance it is
markedly better than the performance I
got from the 15-inch MacBook Pro for
those types of loads and I still refuse
to throw read raw footage at my laptop
and I'll explain why in a second but
basically I threw a ESR 4k footage at it
for the Tesla cyber truck event and a
handle back just fine
part of this is from better GPU
optimization in Final Cut in catallena
from other video professionals reviewing
this machine things like Premiere and
DaVinci Resolve see some much more
modest improvements like five to ten
percent at best but an improvement is an
improvement and better optimization will
keep this thing getting better over time
so why don't I just headed everything on
the MacBook Pro well you might know I
still shoot everything in red raw not
pro res and these are my render times
for a five-minute unedited clip just to
transcode an export before I even upload
it and of course you know these videos
are a little longer than five minutes
they're usually closer to ten multiple
Clips color correction
graphics whatever else so it sort of
scales up from that so uh yeah it
doesn't really make sense I still need a
desktop that's why I travel with an iMac
pro when I shoot red I do this to myself
so ok they fixed the keyboard they fixed
the thermal profile performance is
better they maxed out the battery and on
top of all of that they've improved the
built-in microphone with a much better
signal-to-noise ratio so you listening
to right now it's really good for a
laptop webcam not gonna deny that I
wouldn't say it's studio quality but
it's definitely very good it's just a
shame they paired it again with this
Charmin soft 720p webcam or it could
have been a pretty sweet little video
setup anyway the speakers are also
improved - holy crap level they are
incredible I've never heard speakers in
any other laptop this good and this loud
now I don't know what that means if
you're gonna you know not carry a
Bluetooth speaker anymore if or if you
can just fill a room with music or
listen to videos really loud whatever it
is it's gonna be great at for me the use
case was when I was in LA I forgot the
wire for my headphones so when editing
that cyber truck video I just used the
built-in speakers and this thing was the
real deal even over the previous
excellent macbook pro speakers the main
difference really is the new forced
canceling woofers which you'll notice
offer more bass and just generally a
more impressive high volume sound so to
the listen to the people committee over
at Apple a round of applause well done
but while I have your attention there's
a couple other things that I think if
you want to listen to the people that
you could really do to take this laptop
to the next level the port's first of
all I know you're not gonna bring back
full-size USB but since it's a full size
laptop maybe one or two other USB type-c
ports give us six instead of four and
then SD cards I know this is something
you don't want to bring back but as far
as people I know that use a MacBook Pro
or just creative professionals I know
pretty much 100% of them use SD cards
even I shoot - these little SSDs in this
camera but for audio SD card and I know
the argument would typically be just
plug in whatever accessory you have I a
USB type-c but having that SD card
reader for just universal memory reading
would be just just bring that back and
then
teehee I feel like this is more of a
nice-to-have but having LTE or a
cellular option would make it feel like
more of a complete mobile workstation
and be able to work on the train and
more in between places that don't have
Wi-Fi I do that a lot with the iPad pro
I would love to have that on a macbook
pro and then while I'm at it I wish
there was a black option maybe even
matte black like the surface laptop this
space gray here honestly looks just kind
of like a slightly darker silver maybe
it's just me whatever you can always get
more into it and dbrand it to make it
whatever color you want I do brand like
every laptop I use but the inside being
black would have been cool too and then
take everything every improvement you
just made with this 16 inch MacBook Pro
and do it to the 13 inch MacBook Pro
because as long as that 13 inch laptop
is sitting there with those bigger
bezels with that older keyboard and with
that not so great thermal design it's
gonna be really hard to keep
recommending it even though that's the
size of laptop that I'm more likely to
want so wrap that all up in the 13-inch
make it a 14 inch macbook pro and that
would be pretty sweet there's rumours
Apple may do this around the next gen
that Intel 10th gen and that would be
fantastic but we'll just have to see but
yeah in the meantime overall this is the
best laptop they've ever made as it
should be and I hope this imaginary
committee at Apple that I just made up
and I hope actually exists keeps doing
their thing across the rest of the Apple
lineup also speaking of doing your thing
only a couple days left less than a week
to get in on this drop of mkbhd merch if
you want to get it for the holidays or
if you know someone who wants to get it
for the holidays and this is your time
to get in you know what to do link is
below until the next one thank you very
much for watching catch you later peace